For the most part,
the way Congress works and has worked for many years now is the speaker of the
house has to let it go through. If the speaker says, no, it's not moving. Um,
the speaker has amassed a tremendous amount of power.
This probably started in the Gingrich days. This was before my time, of course,
um, and has continued and has, has gotten, um,
with successive speakers has gotten worse. For example,
during my time in Congress, John Bayner a man. I tried to oust from Congress.
I tried to oust him from the speakership. I didn't want to be a speaker anymore.
Cause I thought he was so bad.
He actually ran a more open Congress than Paul Ryan or Nancy Pelosi.
And that's hard to believe, like if I could go back in time and say to 'em,
you know, pass Justin Amash, Hey, this is actually as good as it gets right now.
I would have probably changed my approach to it and said, Hey,
I guess we were going to stick with John Bayner for now,
but I tried to oust him cause I thought he was so bad. I mean,
this was a guy who one time called me a terrorist and I still, um,
you know, think he was probably the best speaker. Um,
we've had overall because he was, he cared about, uh,
opening up the process, uh,
relative to his successors. Um,
it wasn't a super open process,
but at least we could offer amendments on the house floor from time to time.
And we don't have any of that now.
So why do these bills get presented without the
opportunity for amendment? It is that,
cause it sounds like that's a big part of the problem is that, well, Hey,
it's taking her, leave it. And then you're like,
well I guess like if I can't change it,
I'm going to have to say no to this thing. Um, when did that become the norm?
So, um, until about 2016, May, 2016,
which is a while Paul Paul Ryan was speaker. It was,
uh, the tradition of the house that, uh, particularly, uh,
particularly on appropriations bills. So these are the spending bills.
You had something called an open process where any member of the house
could come to the house floor during the reading of the bill and offer an
amendment. And as long as the amendment was germane to the bill,
that member would get a vote on that amendment.
So we would have votes on all sorts of things, especially like I said,
an appropriations bills and, um, that,
that was the tradition of the house for, uh, you know, over 200 years.
And then along comes Paul Ryan. And he says,
you know, the Democrats are trying to put in these poison pill amendments,
they are offering amendments that are causing, um,
our members to have really tough votes.
And we don't want to have these tough votes.
So what he told the Republican conference, cause I was there at the, uh,
when he announced this, he said, look,
we're going to shut down the open process. Um,
you guys can bring your amendments and present them to the rules committee.
And I will allow a lot of amendments to go through and
be voted on the floor, but I will be able to weed out the, the, um,
as he called them, you know, the, the dangerous or poison pill,
democratic amendments, we can weed those out.
And Republicans were sitting there in the room and they were like, yes, yes,
let's do this. And I objected, I said, this is crazy.
And first of all, he's telling you, he's going to just weed out these, um,
you know, a poison pill amendments.
He's going to weed out all sorts of amendments once,
once this process starts and what's the end game.
So what happens when the Democrats are in charge, then they're like, you know,
ending Republican amendments,
this is a dangerous game to play and we shouldn't be doing this.
We should have an open process. We are a body, um,
where we're supposed to discover the outcomes through the legislative process.
But, you know, I lost that argument and Republicans went forward with that.
They shut down the amendment process.
And Paul Ryan became the first speaker in the history of our country to have a
whole term where we had no open amendments. In other words, there,
there was never a piece of legislation during his whole term that he was speaker
of the full, the full term.
He served as speaker where we were allowed to go to the floor and offer an
amendment.
And Nancy Pelosi has carried that on during her tenure as speaker.
She is not allowed a single open process, um,
during her entire tenure as speaker during this recent tenure, I,
I can't speak for before. She must have allowed it before,
but recently she's followed the precedent set by Paul Ryan and
that's really bad for the American people. It's really,
really bad. Um, I mean, we could talk about this for a long time, but it,
it affects everything. It affects executive power, for example,
uh, I'll give you, um, just, just to,
to flush that out a little bit.
If the president of the United States knows that he only has to negotiate with a
couple people, it makes his job a lot easier.
He can get what he wants a lot more easily than if he has to negotiate with the
entire Congress.
So you've just given the president a tremendous amount of leverage by closing
down the process that the, uh,
framers of the constitution never intended the president to have.
And he only has to negotiate with Nancy Pelosi and Mitch McConnell essentially.
Right? There's only two people.
He has to get it through because they run the whole show.
Nobody else has any say. Now people say to me,
when I say let's open up the process, let some let's allow amendments, Oh,
this will take forever, Justin, this will it'll. You'll slow everything down.
Well, first of all, we,
we spent a lot of time on things we don't need to be spending time on in
Congress. I mean, there's like a lot of stuff that.
No, no, I just want to stop here for a second, Justin.
And just joke that it's like, Oh,
because Congress has such this model of legislative efficiency right now that if
you were to allow amendments that you'd be interfering with this well-oiled
machine that is just humming along.
Anyone,
anyone looking at it right now knows that Congress is not working
efficiently under this model.
This model of minutia negotiates with Pelosi and McConnell is
not efficient. It's taken months look at the COVID relief stuff.
It's yeah, it's taken months and months to get anything.
And then they just, they negotiate for a couple of weeks.
Then the president says something on Twitter, and then they're like, Oh, we're,
we're stopped. We're going to stop negotiating now. And then he says, no, no.
I changed my mind. And they started again, this has been going on, um,
for months, for months now.
And if you just put legislation on the house floor and allow us all
to participate every single member, if Justin Amash has an idea,
let me offer it for people who say that it'll slow down the process to offer
amendments. It won't slow down the process. It will speed up the process. And,
and you know, what else, you know, what else happens?
Every member of Congress then feels like they participated in the process.
And so it brings them on board and brings their constituents on board with
whatever the final packages. Because now you can say to your constituents,
I offered an idea that you guys really wanted,
my constituents wanted this thing.
I went into the house floor and I offered it as an amendment,
but it didn't pass it failed.
So this is the product that is the compromise of the house of
representatives. And a lot of members will then say, well,
this is the best we can do.
And this is something that I'd be willing to vote for.
There are other members who say, no, I'm not willing to vote for it.
And that's okay too.
But the fact is we went through a process and we got something that,
uh,
in a much better way reflects the will of the American people and reflect the
representatives of the people there using their judgment on behalf of the
people.
Why do you think more has not been made of the fact that the legislative process
now, uh, shuts down the ability to amend? Um,
because at this point it's been in effect since 2016, uh,
we can see some of the negative effects. People are very, uh,
upset about how, uh,
unresponsive Congress has been to crisis after crisis at this point.
And COVID relief is the crisis of the moment. Uh,
I have not heard that much in the press, uh, beating up, um, either Paul,
Ryan or Nancy Pelosi for shutting down amendments.
And it seems like a fundamental problem. Would you agree, first of all,
with the sense that this is somewhat under.
Oh, it's way under reported and I've complained to reporters about it.
I've said, this is like, this is the big story,
because when I go to town halls and I talk to my constituents and, um,
you know,
obviously we haven't been doing in person town halls with the COVID situation,
but, uh, back in the day, they would say to me, Justin,
um, you know, the process is all fine at all. Like, it's,
it's nice that there's some procedural problems,
but we care about the substance. We need to get this to spill.
And I say to them, you can't get that bill that you want.
You can't get that idea that you want without an open process.
There's no way for a member of Congress to bring that to the floor
to offer it. So
there's this expectation that I,
as a member of Congress can go and just offer things and have
votes on them. And that's just not true. Um, I can't even tweak bills.
So let alone, I mean, forget the idea of offering my own bill.
I can't even amend bills. So that is a real problem.
And it's under reported, I think, because it's just not a sexy topic,
like really.
Cause this strikes me as very, very weird in the sense that it's very impactful.
I mean, you and I.
Yeah. You know, I think this is like in our wheelhouse where,
you know, I'm, to me, I'm like a procedure person. This is sort of how I think,
I think about process. Um,
because if you control the process that has a big impact on the outcome.
So the way the, the, um,
leadership teams are controlling the process now in both the house and Senate
that impacts the outcome very directly,
I would hope that we can all agree on following a process that allows
everyone to participate so that the libertarian can offer
ideas on the house floor. The progressive can offer ideas on the house floor.
The conservative can offer ideas on the house floor.
We want to bring all of these viewpoints to this
magnificent body that was created in our country,
this magnificent body to, uh,
to legislate on behalf of the American people.
We want to bring all of these viewpoints there and work to persuade each other,
but I can't do that until we fix the procedural process
stuff. So my focus, my focus really has been on that.
Thank you for listening in. I hope you enjoyed this conversation. If you did,
please do subscribe to yang,
speaks and click on notifications so we can let you know every time we have a
new episode.